MALE SPEAKER: Hello, everybody.
Welcome to this talk on
[INAUDIBLE] to green.
So we have Mr. Gauranga Das from
the Govardhan Ecovillage, which
is a model community
that's based
on this principle of
sustainable living and putting
into practice what
we believe in.
So basically, foundation
of this principle
is that, as Mahatma
Gandhi said, there
is enough for everybody's
need, but there's not
enough for everybody's greed.
So if you have a
lifestyle that's
based on satisfying the
basic needs of human being
and be able to live a healthy,
happy life of a sustainable
nature, that's the
best gift we can
do for our future generations.
So based on this principle,
the Govhardhan Ecovillage
started like 10 years back.
And when we had, in
terms of technologies,
to implement a
sustainable living.
So Gauranga Das is a
metallurgical engineer
from the prestigious Indian
Institute of Technology.
And he's a director
of this project.
We're really happy that he's
here at Google to give us
a talk on some of
the technologies,
as well as any other
questions you may have.
So we'll have the presentation
for about like 40 minutes
and then open up for
questions at the end.
So with that, let's
give a big hand
to welcome Mr. Gauranga Das.
GAURANGA DAS: Good
afternoon, everyone.
On behalf of
Govardhan Ecovillage,
I'd like to make this
presentation-- Symbiotic
Recycling at
Govardhan Ecovillage.
So we have a 75 acre property.
And we're trying to
showcase solutions
to four issues-- food,
water, energy, and waste.
So we have tried out
some interesting methods
to try to provide solutions.
And I'm going to
share with you some
of the things
which we have done.
As you know, economy,
society, and environment--
can they go hand in hand?
So the current paradigm
is that we produce goods,
they're used to by the industry,
used by the population,
and then thrown out.
What do we do with the wastes?
So therefore, with the
increase in energy consumption,
we find that people are using
more energy, creating more
waste, and as a
result, there's also
depletion of water resources.
And we're depleting resources
and increasing wastes.
Ecological resilience is
strained the utmost limits.
And also, even if you
want to handle wastes,
then the cost is exorbitant.
So we found that in
the last 100 years,
that has been a paradigm shift
from decreasing resources
to increasing wastes.
And as a result, we
assume that nature
will subsidize the cost of
converting the wastes back
into resources.
So it doesn't happen
like that because only
to a certain extent
nature will do that.
Therefore, ecological
resilience strained to a limit
is a very interesting
feature, because government
is spending a tremendous
amount of money
to bring things under control.
When we find that
food costs are rising,
air pollution is
increasing, and we
find that transportation
costs is increased,
it becomes extremely
difficult for solid waste
to be transported
and what to speak
of water, which
is such a demand.
And we find that water
is being utilized
for more and more activities.
And the next crisis is seriously
going to be that of water.
So considering
that, we are trying
to figure out what is the root
cause analysis of the problem.
So you find that the root
cause solution, the root cause
is the irreversible conversion
of resources into wastes.
The concept we thought of, if we
could devise a system by which
the wastes could be converted
back into resources then
the problem of increasing
waste and decreasing resources
could be solved, because
we'll have a sustainable loop.
Then, ecological
resilience strained
to a limit, if the waste
becomes a resource, then
you a reversible system which
is very close to nature,
because that's what
nature naturally does.
And the increasing
cost of waste handling
would be irrelevant, because
your waste is actually
becoming a resource.
So therefore, waste--
in definition--
is an object which neither in
partial or totality contributes
to the end goal of a system.
So we have two kinds of waste--
immediate waste and delayed
waste.
And therefore, we were
trying to figure out
a concept where the
waste could actually
become the resource
for the next system.
Then that second
system produces a waste
that, if it becomes a
resource for the third system,
then through this
methodology, we'll
have something called a
symbiotic recycling, where
every waste is
becoming a resource.
And in one sense, we
are trying to remodel
what naturally
happens in nature.
In nature, we go
through the cycle.
And the cyclical
chain takes one system
to the next system in a
smooth, seamless fashion.
We also find it
in the water cycle
and in the nitrogen cycle, where
seamlessly, one system just
merges into the other system,
because the waste of one system
becomes a resource
for another system.
So therefore, in a linear
model, what we find
is that the resource being
consumed converts into waste.
So this is a linear
resource-to-trash model,
where at the end of
all the resources,
you're left with a
whole lot of wastes.
And we do not have any
clue how to deal with them.
Whereas, in a system
of symbiotic recycling,
instead of the resource
being converted
to waste as a consumer,
the resource actually
converts into a waste and
waste one becomes resource two.
So it actually
becomes a contributor.
So we are devising a system by
which the consumer is no longer
called a consumer, he will
be called a contributor.
And therefore,
this is the system
which we're trying to
apply in our ecovillage.
And I'll share with you
the details very soon.
So basically,
sustainability is defined
as the interface between
bearability, viability,
and equitability when
social, environment,
and economic factors interface.
So when we are discussing
the whole concept
of sustainability,
then human society,
if it has to remain for
long periods of time,
has to be in this
operating zone.
Therefore, the top 10
problems of the world
is global warming, economic
collapse, peak oil and energy
consumption, urbanization,
water crisis, malnutrition,
nuclear proliferation,
war, terrorism,
and loss of biodiversity.
And at the ecovillage, we try to
integrate all of these factors
together.
And we try to address the issue
of global warming by making
green buildings and integrating
a green waste management
system, global economic
collapse with rural empowerment,
peak oil and energy consumption/
energy crisis by using
alternative energy
and using animals,
urbanization and population
by rural empowerment,
global water crisis with our
water conservation and soil
biotechnology-- which is a
green technology for sewage
management, which I'll be
sharing with you right now--
malnutrition and food security
issues by using organic
agriculture, and loss of
biodiversity and species
extinction with also
organic agriculture.
So basically, ours was a
community set up in 2003.
You must have a lot of
place called Mumbai,
and 108 kilometers away
from Mumbai on the north
is the Govardhan Ecovillage.
And the concept of GEV's based
on sustainable technologies,
which are very effective
in urban, semi-urban,
and rural areas.
As far as waste is concerned,
four types of waste
are created in our property.
We have animal waste
and food waste.
Second is we have dry,
biodegradable waste
like foliage.
And then you have
non-biodegradable--
that is plastics and
construction aggregate.
And human waste, the black
and grey water, et cetera,
which constitute the sewage.
So therefore, how do
we fit in the puzzle
with all of these wastes
being put together?
So let's spend a few moments
on this picture, where
the entire concept of
symbiotic recycling
is explained at one glance.
So you look at to figure
where there is this cow.
So the cow eats on the
grass and it gives cow dung.
OK, so the input for
the cow is the grass.
The grass is the
fodder for the cow.
The output from the
cow is the cow dung.
So interestingly enough for
many of you-- who may or may not
know-- one of the
best forms of manure
which we have experimented
with is made with cow dung.
So cow dung is one of the
top-notch fertilizers which
actually creates such
a fertile ground.
So if you leave the cow
and the earth alone,
both will sustain each other.
The earth will give grass.
The cow will eat the
good, give cow dung.
That cow dung will give more
grass when it hits the ground.
And in this way, both take care
of each other perfectly well.
It's a sustainable system.
But then, you bring
in human being.
So the human, he wants to live.
OK, so naturally, he
cannot live under the sky.
So he needs a house to live.
OK, so what do we do?
The human being needs three
things-- a house to live,
a food to eat,
energy to sustain.
So if you look at this
figure, you find a hut.
That house is made
with mud blocks.
So we created 250,000
blocks made out of mud,
adding 8% cement, and
they're called compassed,
stabilized earth blocks.
It's called green building.
It's called green earth blocks.
So when you have buildings which
are made out of earth blocks,
then it's a breathing
wall and you have very low
embodied energy.
OK, so you have created
a dwelling place
which is as green as possible.
But then, he also
needs food to eat.
So how does the food come?
So from the cow dung,
you have other kinds
of crops which can be grown.
So on that card what
you see is rice.
So one of the greatest
challenges in India
is also to preserve the
indigenous varieties of rice.
So on our property, we grow 54
varieties of indigenous rice.
And you'll be amazed to know
that some of those varieties
are highly medicinal
in property.
And simply by consuming
those varieties of rice,
many of the medical
problems can be solved.
So therefore, indigenous
varieties of rice--
but without using harmful
chemical pesticides
and fertilizers-- and with
that, the organic farming
you grow this food.
So the input for
that is the cow dung.
The output is the food.
Then, the food is eaten
by the human being.
And then, what comes out-- now
you need the food to be cooked.
So how do you use that?
So the cow dung,
again, is used in what
is known as a bio-gas plant.
So in a bio-gas plant,
cow dung becomes an input.
And what comes out is fuel.
And that fuel is
used for cooking.
And that cooking
ultimately cooks
the food which the
humans can eat.
And then, after the humans
eat that, what comes out
is the sewage.
So you see on the right side
is this rectangular structure.
That is the sewage
treatment plant,
which is known as the
soil biotechnology plant.
And we'll discuss
about that also.
But that input for
that is the sewage.
The sewage comes
out, and it goes
through that sewage
technology plant.
And what comes out
is fish fit water.
Fish fit water means water
in which fishes can dwell.
But it's a completely
green sewage technology
with hardly any downtime and
practically no sound at all.
And it is composed of rocks in
different layers, geofigures,
earthworms, and various
kinds of bio-reactors
which generate over 10 million
liters of sewage-- sewage water
can water 10 million liters
of fresh water every year.
And that output, which
is irrigatable water,
goes into irrigation.
That output becomes the
input for the fields.
And then again, the
same chain continues.
So we have in this
way created a system
by which every output
is becoming an input.
And thus, we are regenerating
sources of energy
which we would not
have thought of before.
So this is, in brief, what
we are trying to describe.
So therefore, food, shelter,
and energy is required.
And what human being
generates is waste, sewage,
construction waste,
and domestic waste.
OK, so fulfilling the
human need, food is there,
the grain is there, the
milk products is there.
And this is the actual
pictures of what
we are grown there on our plant.
We have 100 varieties
of mango, also.
Mango is a fruit which
grows very famously
in [INAUDIBLE] in that area.
So we have sugar cane,
rice, [INAUDIBLE]
and various kinds
of organic fruits.
And if you see
here, what you see
in that [INAUDIBLE]
bed is earthen bricks.
That is a construction
waste which
is utilized for creating
permanent and raised bed
system.
So the permanent
raised bed system
is a technique by
which you increase
the productivity
of organic farming.
And we can use all
kinds of wastes
which are generated from
construction for creating that.
So we also have an
animal farm, where
we protect all these
different kinds of animals.
And there's a whole free
range available for them to go
and graze.
And we have created very
huge, nice facilities for them
to feel completely
protected and at ease.
On a regular basis, every week,
all of the community members
go and brush these
animals-- these cows
and other animals--
with brushes.
And we have created such
a beautiful relationship
with them that they
feel totally at ease
and very, very friendly with
anyone who approaches them.
And they also give
very nice milk.
So then we have--
as far as food is
concerned-- that is taken care.
Then as far as that
accommodation--
compressed and
stabilized earth blocks.
So these are some of
the guest rooms which
we have created with
the CSEB-- Compressed
to Stabilized Earth Blocks.
So basically, it is
one portion of cement
to six portion of sand.
And the rest is all--
one cement, one mud,
and four stone dust.
The difference
between the energy
consumed you can see--
72.3 megajoules per kg
versus 0.275 megajoules per kg.
A compressed to
stabilized earth block
has such low embodied energy.
So you are saving such a major
amount of carbon footprint,
just by deciding not to
utilize paint and plaster
method for making walls.
And thus, we find
that the energy we use
is solar and
bio-gas for cooking.
These are some of
the solar panels.
And what you see on the
right-hand bottom side
is what is known
as a bio-gas plant.
You see the [INAUDIBLE] moving.
So that is known as ADPM--
Animal Driven Prime Mover.
So it is connected
to a gear system.
And then it helps
pump the water out.
And that water is utilized for
irrigating the fields nearby.
And then, we have handling
of human waste, construction
waste, and other construction
material inercity.
And basically, recycling
the non-biodegradable wastes
is done in various ways.
We use it for waterproofing
of roof in construction.
Because for
waterproofing, you need
many of these bricks which are
broken and not in good shape.
They are utilized for
waterproofing of the roof.
The dust which is generated
during construction
is used for making agarbatti--
or incense sticks-- made out
of cow dung.
So it's a cow product-based
small scale industry.
Then, as I showed in
the picture before,
the bricks which are
broken down can also
be used for making permanent
raised-bed technology.
Then, many of these
leaves and grasses
which are part of biodegradable
waste are used for mulching.
Mulching is a technique by which
you cover the plants around
so that they get some
kind of fertilizer.
And at the same time, the
moisture which is there
is retained.
And the plastics
and others are also
used as-- suppose cement
bags are generated.
So if the cement
bags are there, we
use them for composting
and plant bags.
We are re-utilizing
them that way.
And some of the
other wastes we use
in the walls for
which we make cob.
So cob house is
actually mud house,
but the walls can
actually be filled
with various kinds
of wastes which
are around-- say bottles or
tires or anything can be put
inside, and then covered
over and plastered with mud.
So a lot of wastes
are also re-utilized
in the walls of the cob house.
So in this way, we
are trying to use
the non-biodegradable
wastes in this fashion.
Then we have the domestic waste
and the food and cattle waste.
And other biodegradable waste,
all that is used in composting.
Because it can be
composted, and it
can be used as manure
for agriculture.
So, the whole community,
it is very sensitive
to separate all of these wastes.
Because as you know,
the number one principle
of waste management is
separation at source.
And if we do not
separate at source,
we cannot have a successful
waste management plan.
So therefore, this
composting unit
is utilized in organic farming.
So it is used in
bio-gas plant, and it
comes from cow barn, organic
farming, and community kitchen.
These are the three sources of
giving us animal waste and food
waste inputs.
So all of these three go
into the bio-gas plant
and give energy.
The input is from these wastes.
The output is energy which
is utilized for cooking.
So this is a picture of that.
And then, we have
the last, which
is the sewage-- or human waste.
And that is recycled in what is
known as the soil biotechnology
plant.
And the soil biotechnology
plant is actually
an IET Mumbai patented plant.
It is created by a Doctor
Biplab Patnaik, who
was one of my classmates
from IET Mumbai.
And I knew when he was doing
his PhD in '90, '93, '94,
in that period.
So Professor Shankar
and Dr. Biplab Patnaik
created this technology.
And the principle is very
simple-- water, by nature,
regenerates.
Even you don't drink
water for a few hours,
you feel energy going down.
So as soon as you start drinking
water, you generate energy.
As soon as the plants get
water, they start generating.
So water is a
regenerating medium.
Whereas, the earth is best
for these degeneration,
because the number of
bacteria which are in earth
is several hundred times
more than the bacteria
which is there in water.
So therefore, the
degradation and degeneration
happens more effectively,
more efficiently,
naturally, in earth
than in water.
So previously, all
of the wastes would
be actually dumped
in the outside.
And people would
in the out and then
they would respond to
the call of nature.
Then we had this
flush-driven toilet system.
So because of the
flush-driven toilet system,
we had water as the
medium for transporting
all of the gray and black water.
So as a result, what do you
do with all of that waste?
So the statistics reveal that
very few municipalities all
over the world-- city
councils all over the world--
take the trouble of actually
processing that waste
before they dump
it into the ocean.
So the majority of
the times, it just
goes, because the cost of
handling that is enormous.
So the thought
behind SBD was that,
since you cannot now tell
people to go out-- you know,
they have to use the toilet,
so as far as water-based,
gravity-driven sewage
system is concerned,
that cannot be replaced.
But what if that water which
is brought through the sewage
system can finally be
processed through a soil-based,
earth-based,
purification system?
So it is combining
the ancient wisdom
of using earth as a purifying
medium with the modern usage
of the flush toilet system.
So then we have what is
known as SBD bio-reactor.
It goes into the SBD
system-- the human waste.
And output which comes
out is fish-fit water
which is used for
nursery and landscaping.
OK, so basically, the SBD
is very powerful system.
Why?
Because septic tank-based
system is-- many times,
it creates foul
odor and it clogs,
and then it spills
over and creates
lot of difficulties in
rural areas especially.
So here, when we have
an SBD-based system--
so we have at least 10
million liter of water
to be used for irrigation.
Number two, the
solid waste-- it also
creates photosynthetic biomass
for internal use, which
is like manure.
So basically, this is how
a schematic looks like.
This is the stage one
of the SBD system,
where from the last manhole,
then the pipe comes in,
then you see those two
perforated screens-- that
separates the solid
waste from the liquid--
and then the liquid comes
in, goes on a settling tank,
and the overflow goes
into the next tank, which
is called the collection tank.
From the collection tank
through a transfer pump,
it is fed in through
the feed lines
into the SBD bio-reactive unit.
So you see those rocks,
they appear as hard rocks.
But they're not hard rocks.
When you have a lot of
mud which is hardened
over a period of
time, naturally, then
has as a fantastic
phenomenon of being hard,
but at the same
time it is porous.
It is porous because it allows
the water to flow through.
At the same time, even
if water flows through,
it will not disintegrate
like regular mud.
It will not flow with the mud.
So that is one of the
secrets of this plant.
And along with that, you
add geophagus earthworms
who have a natural tendency
off purifying and converting.
So then, along with that,
you have specific kinds
of plants which
you grow in that.
And when you do that, what comes
out is this fish-fit water.
And this is how the
SBD unit looks like.
If you look at it
from outside, this
is a sewage treatment plant.
It looks like a garden.
These are the papayas
which are grown there.
And you know, there is a
whole discussion going on
that these papayas look
bigger than the normal.
They're well fed--
powerful looking.
And you'll see in
the bottle, it's
the purified water which
is completely clear.
So impact assessment,
if you see,
that as far as treatment is
concerned-- sludge handling is
concerned, aeration
is concerned--
is SBD-- the soil
biotechnologies-- scores
over the conventional
unit hands down.
Why?
Because practically no chemical
is required for treatment.
Sludge handling
hardly is required,
because we have around two
and a half kilometers--
yeah, two kilometers
of line which come in.
And by the time it
comes in, the water
has already kind of taken care
of all of the solid wasted.
So comes out is like
a liquid slurry.
So sludge handling
is hardly there.
And thirdly, as far as
aeration is concerned,
there is no requirement
for aeration,
because it's a simple,
gravity-driven,
you know, earth-based,
rock-based system.
So there's no need for aeration.
So there's no need for
high mechanization.
There's no downtime required.
There is no sound
created, so it can
be installed very close
to human dwellings.
Because conventional septic
tanks and conventional units
for STPs-- sewage
treatment plants--
cannot be installed very
near where people stay
because of the sound it
creates for the aeration unit.
And so we can see such a low
energy expended for one liter
sewage is less than
0.01 kilowatt hour.
So these are some
of the advantages.
It's sustainable, ease
of installation, recovery
efficiency-- we practically
recover 95% of the water--
and we are, as I said, 10
million liters of freshwater
we are generating.
And it's power saving.
And also, we have this biomass
flowers, bio-fertilizers,
and we have a whole garden
which is created around that.
So flowers and fruits are
generated also along with that.
The BOD, the COD, the
units-- if you compare,
it's very, very low,
you can see that.
The standard specification
is maximum 250.
So in December, 2012 and Jan.
2013 when we began, we
have some of these figures.
So you can see the treated
water is 42 and 38.
Right?
Chemically oxidized,
and then BOD.
So biological also--
it's 18 and16,
which is much less than
the standard specification.
Suspended solids are very
less, and total dissolved
solids which also came
out to be extremely low.
Standard specification is
2,100, here we had 402.
So overall, we have found
that this symbiotic recycling
has turned out to be great.
As far as cost is concerned,
we are recovering the cost,
and we are saving
a lot on energy.
We are saving on the
monthly cost a net savings.
And in this way, we can see
that the value created by SBD
is also tremendous,
because it saves us
around 35,000 rupees per annum
on the water being generated
and 2 million tons of biomass.
And what to speak of
the co-products which
are produced as a result of
the waste created from the cow
dung?
And this is a 10
million liter pond.
You see the mountains behind
are called the Sahyadri Mountain
Ranges.
It's one of the top biodiversity
hotspots in the world.
The monsoons hit against that,
now it's lashing like anything.
July to September, you'll get
3,000 millimeters of rain.
London gets around 500 to 600.
So in this three to four
months, the amount of rain
which falls-- so we
need to conserve that.
Because as you know, India's
population is 1.2 billion,
out of which 820 million
live in villages.
And villages very
much live upon water.
So therefore, if we
create a model by which we
show an ideal example
of water conservation,
it can transform the
landscape of the country.
So the step one in doing
this water consideration
is what is known as
hydrogeological survey.
So there is a firm
called ACWADAM in Pune,
and we employed them.
And they did a complete
hydrogeological survey,
which means they showed the
movement of the ground water
under your property.
And they showed the potential
moment of the rainwater
once the rain hits, depending
on the topography of the land.
So it costs a little
bit to do this survey,
but once you do that, you have a
very accurate estimate of where
you must try to
conserve the rainwater,
and where you should
dig the wells.
And this water conservation
is closely connected
to organic farming.
Why?
Because one of the major
culprits for groundwater
contamination is fertilizers
and insecticides.
And when the rains
fall, then the rains
percolate down into
the groundwater
and pollute the aquifers.
And when the overflow
comes through,
it pollutes all the
rivers and the ponds.
All of this rainwater
carries the insecticides
and the pesticides with them.
So if we think that we can
separate water conservation
from farming, it
is not possible.
Because what we
use as fertilizers,
pesticides, and insecticides
in our organic farming
will ultimately come
back in the form
of contaminated groundwater.
So therefore, we partnered with
the government of Maharashtra.
And we had a geo-membrane
laid in this particular patch
of land.
And according to the
hydrogeological survey,
this place was shown to be the
best for conserving the water.
So the water hits against
the mountains, flows down
the mountains, and this
10 million liters water
is filled up in three
day of rainfall.
In three days of rainfall,
it is full and overflowing.
And then we have
created a channel
through which it goes farther.
And then, we have
created-- this is actually
what you call as a
rainwater harvesting unit.
Then you have
another unit-- which
is called percolation
tank-- by which
we allow the rainwater
to go through the earth,
down, and regenerate
the aquifers.
So all of the extra water from
here goes into the other pond.
And then, that pond
actually percolates down.
And overall, in the
last four years,
we have seen that our
groundwater levels have come up
by three feet because of
continuous percolation.
So in this way, we can see
that the linear systems prove
to be injurious,
costlier and inadequate.
Symbiotic systems
are more efficient.
And these systems which
are implemented in GEV
can be scaled up.
And we already in
dialogue with FICI--
which is Federation of
Indian Chamber of Commerce
and Industry-- and CII--
Chamber of Indian Industries--
and also the government
of Maharashtra.
And we are trying ways and means
by which this can be scaled up,
and the example can be utilized
in various other places.
We have tried it
to great success,
and it is up to the government
and the corporate agencies
to utilize the
resources to scale it up
for the help of society.
An SBD is definitely a quite
green and more effective
than any other system.
So these are some of the
thoughts on Govardhan
Ecovillage Symbiotic Recycling.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Do you have a sense
of how large a community this
could be scaled up to,
or is that entirely
dependent on the geography?
GAURANGA DAS: Basically,
there is a certain thumb rule,
as far as community
is concerned.
Say for 75 acres,
we don't want to go
beyond 200 people
living in a community.
Because there's a very
short amount of food,
and the milk, and the grazing
land, and things like that.
Ideally, for the cows, you
require very high degrees
of grazing land.
But we are next to a forest
area in an open range
and next to the mountains,
so we can afford that.
But then, we have
to be very sure
that we can't go on
unlimitedly scaling up.
So the number of people and the
number of hard construction you
do on a particular
piece of land should
be very sensitively designed.
And that will depend very
much on the local topography.
So we are living in a
very high rainfall area.
And we are in zone three.
And also, we have what
is known as black soil.
So the black soil is
something which is very clay.
And so, the foundations
which we require to build
are quite deep.
So therefore, the
intervention in the earth
is much more than regular.
So we have to be very sensitive
how much we can actually build.
So at this stage, we
are kind of reached
our limits of development as
far as our land is concerned.
AUDIENCE: Have you
worked with the SBD
separately from
the whole solution?
It sounds like something
that could be implemented
as just one component
in other communities.
And if so, again,
how large would you
be able to scale that?
GAURANGA DAS: So
if you Google SBD,
then you'll find all the
works of Professor Shankar
and some of the places
they're installed.
So this company, which
Biplab runs-- my friend,
Biplab Patnaik runs-- it's
called Lifelink Solutions.
And proposition
Professoer Shankar-- he
installed first in Mumbai
Municipal Corporation.
So, very much the city of Mumbai
also installed part of that.
One of the issues
in the initial days
was processing of
chemical wastes.
So they ran into
issues with that.
But now, after several years
of scaling up and tweaking
that system,
currently they claim
that they have dealt with it.
And they're kind of confident of
dealing with any kind of waste.
So in one sense,
in our community
it's kind of easier, because
we have certain protocols
on not using chemical-based
soaps and other kinds of stuff.
So if you have a
lifestyle paradigm which
is connected to this,
it becomes much easier.
But still, I met some of
the new vendors of the SBD,
and they claim that they're
ready for even direct chemical
plants.
But I personally
have no experience,
but it looks like they've
taken care of that.
But probably, you'll find
more information on the net.
But as far as we're
concerned, definitely we
installed in 2011.
Now, in three years,
practically zero maintenance.
Just we have one guy who
just takes care of it.
His job is to switch on the
pump, switch off the pump,
you know, do a little bit
of cleaning here and there.
He grows his own farm there.
He eats better food
than many of us.
So it's pretty impressive.
AUDIENCE: I guess my question
is, what are the culture
requirements for this to work?
Because I'm trying to
think how would you-- like,
could you transpose this into
the rural Midwest or something
like that?
I'm skeptical.
So what aspects of
the human culture
do you think are required?
GAURANGA DAS: I think a deep
sense of compassion and care
for mother earth.
If you have a deep feeling
that we need to be sensitive.
Because when you
care for someone
you're sensitive towards them.
So if I feel that I
care for mother earth,
I want to be sensitive
towards mother earth.
And therefore, naturally, when
you begin from that point,
then all your priorities,
all your plannings,
all your implementation
will then flow from there.
So I think the concept
basically is care.
So taking this as the
foundational principle,
I think the implementation
of this can be global.
Probably the details
may vary-- as far
as some of the types of
construction you may make,
or the kinds of
food you may grow,
animal you may take
care-- the details may differ.
But in principle, we are
dealing with four things,
as I said-- food, water,
energy, and waste.
And we have showing how we
can integrate all of this.
Because as soon as human
beings come, they create waste.
But how we combine all
of these in such a way
that the waste
becomes a resource.
So therefore, the
details may differ
based on the geography, based
on the particular situation--
the biodiversity of that place--
the climactic zone in which it
is, the earthquake zone in
which it is, so probably some
of the construction materials we
used there may not apply here.
But still, the whole idea
is green construction.
Right?
The idea is low
energy construction.
And methodologies
can be worked out,
based on the particular place.
But the two concepts
which I want to emphasize
is care, and based on
the principle of care,
then we actually implement
something sustainable.
So why not?
So we have the website
called ecovillage.org.in.
So you can visit the website.
ecovillage.org.in.
If you just type ecovillage,
it will come on the front--
AUDIENCE: So how receptive
have local governments
been to the system?
What are the major
difficulties that you've
encountered in dealing
with governments
and trying to get
them to subscribe
to this type of system
and implement it?
GAURANGA DAS: Yeah, one of the
biggest problems is-- just,
you begin from food only.
OK?
As soon as you come
to food, and as soon
as you say organic, then
you how all these giants who
are selling tons and tons
of pesticides, fertilizers,
importing them into India.
And then it's a whole lobby.
You know?
So, as soon as you say
organic, then there
is an existing lobby which
is based on a huge turnover.
And it's not so easy to
push the organic part.
Although the government,
within their initiatives,
they have schemes for
promoting organic farming.
But then, within the bureaucracy
and within the ministers,
then there is such a kind of
integrated working with all
these foreign firms and other
kinds of firms within India
who have vested
interest in selling
those insecticides,
pesticides, and fertilizers.
They may say
something, but to what
extend the implementation
is really genuine
becomes questionable.
Number two, it is not that
organic farming is so simple,
also.
Right?
Just I'll give you an example.
One of the kind of fertilizers
we use is using cow dung.
Now, what the cow does is goes
and eats at various places.
So there are some kinds
of insects the cow eats,
which is locally found there.
And the insect does
a peculiar behavior
that, once it goes into the
cow's stomach, it doesn't die,
but it just kind of survives.
It goes into kind
of hibernation.
And then, when it comes
out with the cow dung,
it is still there.
So then you use the
cow dung as manure,
but then, when it
comes in contact
with the grasses and the
plants, then that insect again,
it starts becoming active.
And that insect starts
eating the plant.
So we have using the
cow dung a manure,
but the cow dung has
sometimes these insects
which act against the interest
of what we are trying.
So these are just some
examples I'm telling you
that it is not always
so simple, even
for suppose a lawn--
a simple lawn.
You just put Urea,
the lawn will look
like green and fresh
and everything.
You try to use the
organic method,
you have to have patience.
You have to spend a lot of time.
So therefore, with patience,
with some kind of understanding
that, yes, there may
be someone difficulties
but we'll stick to it.
If you don't have that kind
of principle-based approach,
then one may become
impatient after some time.
And then say, oh, forget it.
Let's put something
in and get it going.
So that's one of the elements
which we have experienced.
So therefore, when
you're talking
of a statewide or
nationwide implementation
by the government agencies,
you can understand
that it's not so
easy to be patient
and just wait and watch.
And we are talking of
reversing a trend which
has been so deeply rooted
for several decades.
So it's not going
to be also so easy.
Therefore, I call it creating
islands of excellence
in an ocean of chaos.
So when you create
islands of excellence,
so probably to standout
and be noticed, and then
probably others
will be inspired.
And in a small way,
we can try our effort
to create a better place.
OK?
Thank you so much.
So I would now share that video.
Thank you.
So this video was made by
Julie from New York City.
She was so inspired when
she saw the ecovillage.
And Robin Simon from Hollywood,
she came along with a group.
And one of the [INAUDIBLE]
teachers, Sharon Gannon,
was there at that time
they actually videoed.
They took one and one half
hours of film, actually,
but seven minutes--
just a promo-- is here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
REDHANATH SWAMI:
Govardhan Ecovillage
is about 2 and 1/2
hours northeast
of Mumbai in a very
beautiful rural village
area or Maharashtra.
There's a very
holy place in India
which is considered most
sacred to devotees of Krishna,
it's called brindavan.
And in that brindavan is a
mountain named Govardhan, which
represents environmental,
ecological harmony
with spiritual principles.
PADMA SHARON GANNON: This
place is very special.
Certainly, it's unique in
India, and perhaps unique
in the whole world.
It's like a retreat center.
It's like a spa.
It's like an ashram.
It's a place that's
designed as an experiment
to merge
environmentalism, animal
rights, and bhakti--
spirituality-- together.
And it's working.
JULES FEBRE: The amenities
here are a whole other caliber.
People, when they think of
the words India and ashram,
they think of harsh
and rough living.
From the Ayurvedic Clinic,
which not only gives treatments,
but also has a
Ayurvedic doctor who
helps prescribe something
that is specific for your
[INAUDIBLE].
The atmosphere that is created
by the founder, Redhanath Swami
Maharaj, and the atmosphere that
is created by the devotees who
work here is palpable.
You can feel it in the air.
REDHANATH SWAMI: Originally,
I was from Chicago.
When I was 19
years old, in 1970,
I wanted to try to broaden
my outlook of life.
So I went on a journey.
Ultimately, I
hitchhiked from London
to the Himalayas and India.
And as I was traveling,
I came to realize
that the real social and
environmental problems
of the world are due
to a spiritual crisis--
a crisis in what we consider
it's actually meaningful
and fulfilling in our life.
PADMA SHARON GANNON: Redhanath
Swami is a passionate person.
The best passion is
compassion, and he
has a ample amount of that.
And that type of
passion is contagious.
DAVID VINAS: To be
coming here and helping
do the seva-- or the service--
helping with the cows,
helping to weave mats,
helping them make pottery,
it's actually fun.
It's very simple lifestyle.
And I think a lot of us crave
that on different levels.
MICHELLE BAKER: It's sort of
programmed into our culture
that you look for
recognition, you need it.
For me, being here, I see it's
far more powerful to be humble.
NICK VELCOV: It was
easy to complain
about the tiny inconveniences
that come with a New York City
apartment.
Oh, it's not big enough.
Oh, the water pressure
isn't great enough.
When you live in
the house that you
see built from the ground
up, every step along the way,
it's very special.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
REDHANATH SWAMI: When
people come here,
we're trying to inspire an
educational, experiential
alternative of a fulfilling,
meaningful, sustainable,
healthy life.
MALE SPEAKER: Apart
from these jasmine
flowers which you see, he grows
a lot of his lady fingers,
okra.
So we work with
all these farmers
so that we purchase them in
our kitchen and use them.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Can we
get these to the kitchen?
REDHANATH SWAMI:
And the inspiration
of this project-- [INAUDIBLE]
he called this transformation
simple living and high thinking.
GAURANGA DAS: We get 3,000
millimeters of rain, annually.
So the rainwater hits against
those mountains-- the Sahyadri
Mountain Ranges-- and flows
down and collects here.
And it is sufficient
order for us
to irrigate our fields for up to
six to seven months every year.
The majority of
India's population--
which is 1.2 billion--
lives in the villages.
So one of the very
important requirements
to develop a village is
how can water be conserved?
BIPLAB PATNAIK: The
process begins here.
As you can see, the
[INAUDIBLE] is falling.
And there are some screens.
The first chamber is
called screen chamber
where we're trying to
separate floating solids.
This is the groundwater
where it began.
And this the treated water.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GAURANGA DAS: The uniqueness of
this place comes from the fact
that every waste is becoming
a precious resource.
That cow dunk becomes
a fertilizer for earth.
He needs fire or energy
for cooking his food.
And therefore, all
of the cow dung,
we utilize for bio-gas plant.
We need to make houses,
so we use the same earth.
And we have created
250,000 bricks.
We call this a symbiotic
recycling model.
Flushing your toilet,
you are contributing
to the growth of a papaya.
You are contributing to
the growth of flowers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: One of the
greatest management gurus
says that the
greatest management
challenge of the 21st century
is managing one's self.
REDHANATH SWAMI:
Many corporate heads
are having seminars
and retreats here.
And they also see
alternative ways
by which they could focus
their own corporations
and feel a real sense of
responsibility to humanity.
MICHELLE BAKER:
The thing I'm most
compelled to do when I get home
is really seva-- it's service.
It gets us out of
being so self-absorbed.
ANGELA CROCE: I
always had too much.
And now, I want to have a
really simple life like here.
I love simple life
and my goal is
to make a simple
life in my home.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
REDHANATH SWAMI: And if we
just refocus our energies
with these values, we
could transform the world.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's
truly a miraculous,
magical place, this planet.